Доброго дня, шановний пане Гуґ!
Дякую, що знайшли час дляінтерв’ю.
Адже варто підбити деякі підсумки,
оскільки ви залишаєте посаду заступника голови
спеціальної моніторингової місії ОБСЄ на Донбасі
Що для Вас особисто і для місії ОБСЄ
є найбільшим досягненням за ці роки роботи в Україні?
Я вважаю, що протягом цих чотирьох з половиною років
ми спробували спрямувати дискусію щодо конфлікту
у такий бік, щоб більше уваги приділяли мирному населенню,
яке і далі страждає по обидва боки
лінії конфлікту від боїв, що тривають.
Ми спробували і показати це в наших звітах,
ідати зрозуміти у наших розмовах усім учасникам цього конфлікту,
що необхідно вжити заходів для покращення захисту населення.
І кожен захід, який на це спрямований, вітається,
тим більше, що цього дуже бажає місцеве населення.
Чи були протягом цих років ситуації, коли щось пішло не так?
Коли моніторингова місія до конфлікту починала свою роботу в Україні,
вона була доволі маленька. Ми змінилися через конфлікт.
І на початку2014-ого
навряд чи хтось міг подумати, що через чотири з половиною роки
цей конфлікт досі вируватиме на Сході України.
Те, що місія свій внесок зробила, аби конфлікт не поширився далі,
у цьому я упевнений. Конфлікт поки ще не зупинений, звичайно,
і у наших щоденних звітах ми фіксуємо факти того, що перемир’я,
оголошеного ще у2014 році, не дотримуються.
Ви особисто багато бачили у зоні конфлікту на Донбасі.
Але не завжди і не про все могли відверто говорити
через свою роль спостерігачаміжнародної організації.
Як ви при цьому почувалися?
Перш за все варто уточнити, що моніторингова місія
не є службою з аналогічною, як у новин, функцією.
Про все, що ми бачимо і спостерігаємо, ми повідомляємо.
Єдиною умовою є те, що ми повідомляємо лише про те,
що ми дійсно бачили на власні очі.
Було б неправдою, якби я сказав, що в мене не було особистих
суб’єктивних почуттів, коли я бачив усі ці порушення на лінії розмежування.
Як заступник голови місії япредставляю
цю польову операцію ОБСЄ в Європій відповідно,
політичний консенсус п'ятдесяти семи держав-учасниць ОБСЄ.
Тому те, що я як приватна особа думаю про цейконфлікт,
не є частиною моєї роботи.
В одному з інтерв’юви сказали, що війну на Донбасі
можна було б зупинити за одну годину.
Ви - колишній офіцер армії Швейцарії.
Ви дійсно вважаєте, що це можливо?
Ми у минулому бачили,
що якщо сторони конфлікту схилялися до перемир’я,
то упродовж короткого проміжку часу, за ніч,
навіть протягом кількох годин кількість порушень режиму тиші
від тисяч попереднього дня  могла зменшитись до декількох десятків.
Ми знаємо, що це не спекуляції. Ми знаємо, що можна швидко припинити бої.
Для цього потрібне політичне рішення,
а згодом дзеркальне виконання домовленостей
з обох боків лінії розмежування,
щоб ці бої припинилися.
Те, що це можливо, я повторюся,
ми за ці чотири з половиною роки регулярно багато разів фіксували.
І можливо, одне за найважливіших питань, що цікавить багатьох людей.
Є на Донбасі російська армія та російські військові, чи ні?
Спеціальна моніторингова місія має базуватися лише на фактах.
І ми впродовж цих чотирьох з половиною років
у понад тисячі щоденнихзвітах зафіксували багато фактів.
Наприклад, ми говорили з людиною, яка була затримана українськими військовими,
яка нам стверджувала, що є членом формування російської армії
і воювала в Україні за ротацією.
Ми також бачили спеціальний військовий електронний пристрій,
який був відповідно маркований.
Ми описали його у нашому звіті та оприлюднили фотографії.
Ми також бачили 6-7 разів конвої з вантажівок,
які рухались від чи до непідконтрольного уряду України кордону з Росією.
Ті вантажівки були військові.
До того ми фіксували сліди на непідконтрольних ділянках кордону.
Ці всі факти є в наших звітах і говорять самі за себе.
Люди, якічитають наші звіти, учасники конфлікту,
можуть на підставі цих фактів відповідно реагувати,
я маю на увазі, покращувати ситуацію.
На жаль, часто сторони ігнорували ці факти.
Ці факти можуть також лягти в основу доказів.
Але наше завдання полягаєв тому, щоб надавати факти.
В Україні багато людей сумніваються в потребі місії ОБСЄ,
оскільки вона не може вирішити конфлікт, алише спостерігає.
Що б ви відповіли цим людям?
Я розумію розчарування і яподіляю це розчарування
у тому, що конфлікт досі не зупинений.
Утім завдання, яке місія отримала від країн-учасниць ОБСЄ,
зокрема і від України,
полягає у спостереженні за ситуацією.
Сторони, які підписали "мінські домовленості",
а це Москва, Київ і відповідні райони Донеччини та Луганщини,
домовилися про заходи, які вони пообіцяли виконати,
щоб припинити конфлікт.
У їхніх руках завершити цей конфлікт.
А наше завдання - документувати, зробили вони це чи ні.
Як би виглядала ситуація на Донбасі,
якби місії ОБСЄ там не було?
Відповісти точно на це питання неможливо,
адже це було б чистою спекуляцією.
Але я впевнений, що без СММ, без наших щоденних звітів
було б неможливо отримати принаймні загальну картину того,
якою є ситуація на лінії розмежування,
передусім з непідконтрольного Україні боку.
Присутністьспостерігачів по обидва боки контактної лінії
сприяє тому, що насилля не поширюється неконтрольовано
упродовж цих чотирьох з половиною років.
Також завдяки місії стало відомо про потреби людей,
про допомогу,  яка їм необхідна.
І завдяки встановленим нами фактам ця допомога надається.
На Донбасі за цей час було багато жахливих подій
Ракетні обстріли автобусів з мирними жителями
катастрофа МН 17, обстріли автомобілів місії ОБСЄ
Що ви відчували?
Кожний загиблий на лінії розмежування  - це забагато
Кожен поранений - це забагато
Це особливо важко пережити, якщо йдеться про дітей
Я знав дітей у багатьох селищах
і їх же пізніше я бачив вже мертвими
Це дуже важко пережити
І тому так важливо вказувати саме на страждання цивільного населення
адже воно потерпає від початку конфлікту
від військових дій
Чи були ситуації, коли ви особисто потрапляли під обстріли
або хтось намагався вас затримати?
Так, були ситуації
коли патрулі, в яких я перебував, потрапляли під перехресний вогонь
Так було від початку конфлікту
90 патрулів, які місія щоденно відправляє на спостереження
постійно пересуваються в зоні небезпеки
Це було і буде, спостерігачі зіштовхуються з пасивними небезпечними ситуаціями
Місії чинилися і досі чиняться перешкоди
Це відбувається пасивно
коли не розміновують дороги
чи не прибирають інші перешкоди на дорогах, якими ми пересуваємося
Також це відбувається активно, коли нам прямо погрожують
не дають їхати далі або стріляють близько до наших патрулів
Активні перешкоди трапляються на непідконтрольних Українітериторіях
Пасивні перешкоди- по обидва боки лінії зіткнення
У чому полягає різниця між конфліктом на Донбасі
і конфліктами у Боснії і Герцеговині, у Косові, Хевроні, де ви також працювали?
Думаю, не слід їх порівнювати
Усі конфлікти почалися з різних причин
Спільне у всіх конфліктів те, що мирне населення
байдуже з якого боку воно перебуває
безпідставно страждає через цей конфлікт.
А ті, хто має ухвалювати рішення
часто занадто пізно звертають увагу на мирне населення
або взагалі не роблять цього
Т ак було в усіх конфліктах, які я спостерігав
Зокрема і тут, на Сході України
Ви часто спілкувалися з мирними жителями
по обидва боки лінії розмежування
Як ви оцінюєте ситуацію на Донбасі
як пересічний європеєць, не як заступник голови спецмісії ОБСЄ?
Територія від лінії розмежування на 15-20 км
вглиб з обох боків - це дуже небезпечна зона
Там відбуваються активні воєнні дії
Багато цих районів заміновані
Це райони, які ,звичайно, є дуже небезпечними
де мирне населення постійно наражається на небезпеку
Ви відповідаєте як адвокат
яким ви є за освітою
як колишній офіцер армії Швейцарії, як заступник голови місії ОБСЄ в Україні
Можливо, трохи пізніше, ви захочети написати книгу про війну на Донбасі
приміром, про ваш суб'єктивний погляд?
Мені багато разів це пропонували
Насправді у мене є багато спогадів,які залишаться зі мною назавжди
незалежно від того, опублікую я їх в книзі чи ні
Це я ще не вирішив
Правда в тому, що Україна і українці залишаться назавжди зі мною
Я ніколи не забуду ні країну, ні людей
І сподіваюся, що в подальшому я зможу бути корисним для країни
зможу допомагати прямо чи опосередковано
Як ви особисто проводили час вУкраїні?
Які спогади заберете з собою?
Коли яприїхав навесні2014-го, я не знав багато про Україну
Я не знав історії, не знав людей
Із цим незнанням я розпочав свою роботу
І мені здається, що через чотири з половиною роки я розумію українців не до кінця
Але я навчився цінувати українців
особливо те, що вони чинять опір насиллю,
стійкі до насилля
Багато людей, які щоденно мусять зіштовхуватися із насиллям на лінії розмежування
не розвивають в собі ненависть, неприйняття
Навпаки вони сповнені надіїі не здаються
Такої стійкості я ще не бачив
щоб люди через чотири з половиною роки
щоденних небезпек і щоденного насилля
усе ще вірять, що все має завершитися добре
Це незвичайно і я захоплююсь таким ставленням
Я гість уцій країні
я не можу сприймати все як українець
але те, що я побачив на Сході
переконало мене в тому, що цей конфлікт закінчиться
що рішення знайдуть швидко, наскільки це можливо
На цьому усе. Дякую, пане Гуґ
І вам дуже дякую